the attacks are more and more intense
with russian forces now using heavy
weapons in civilian areas
in the second city of kharkiv a
university building crumbles after a
missile strike
it's clearly not a military target
this place is home to one and a half
million people
for those remaining nowhere is safe even
the bomb shelters
i have kids at the age of 8 10 11 12 and
13
they're all of them are afraid they will
destroy kharkiv for sure they have no
limits they have no moral they have no
one human feeling they bombed
the district
where i lived including school the
school when my my kids studying and of
course they see these pictures
and their show
on the south coast on the sea of azov
the situation is also increasingly
difficult
many of the coastal towns are cut off
including mario pool a vital target if
russia's to create a land bridge to
crimea
many of the city's residential areas
have been shelled with fears hundreds of
civilians may have been killed
vladimir putin's forces appear to be
frustrated
the kremlin claims that 498 of its
troops have been killed in the first
admission of casualties in this conflict
but the true number is thought to be
much higher
moscow's supremacy in the sky is obvious
these jets ripping over the town of
urpin before unleashing their bombs
on the ground extensive destruction
these residential buildings in pieces
in the capital kiev not far away the
advance has slowed
but the violence has not
emergency services video shows the
aftermath of a missile strike on the
capitals landmark radio and tv tower
one of the five victims a journalist has
been named as yevheny sakan
the blast spread over a huge area
damaging the holocaust memorial
but people across ukraine are showing
remarkable courage
the mayor of a town in the east rallies
his citizenship
and the resistance is getting stronger
with more and more volunteers joining
local forces
the weapons they have though are no
match for russian firepower
here in dunipro in the eastern part of
the country people are watching the
growing levels of violence with great
fear that are being used against the
civilian population in other cities now
in this place they are fortifying their
defenses
but as another day ends
residents worry that it's only a matter
of time before they too come under
attack
the sirens are sounding more often
it means a heart-pounding trip to the
airaid shelter and a nervous wait for
the danger to pass
news
no one knows how this war will end but
as days turn into weeks
there's a feeling that this may become
even more savage
[Music]
there may not be any respite from
russian aggression
but ukraine says it will continue to
resist
even in the face of great adversity
alex rossi sky news
eastern ukraine